in less than a month US politics will
take center stage when the first ballots
and the Democratic presidential primary
will be cast in Iowa a new CBS News
battleground tracker poll shows a
three-way tie between candidates in that
crucial state senators Bernie Sanders
former Vice President Joe Biden and Pete
Buddha judge each have 30 23 percent
support senators Elizabeth Warren and
Amy Klobuchar trail behind in New
Hampshire senator Sanders is in front
with a two-point lead over Biden and
O'Keefe is in Davenport Iowa and what
else stands out to you in this poll well
good morning the poll finds that here in
Iowa and in New Hampshire Bernie Sanders
has the most enthusiasm among his
supporters while Joe Biden is seen as
the safest bet notably none of these
candidates have convinced a majority of
Democratic primary voters that they
could defeat president Trump that's
important because in the last year
Democrats have consistently said they're
most concerned about finding someone to
win back the white house throughout the
weekend foreign policy dominated the
conversation given the recent killing of
iranian major-general Qasem Soleimani
most Democrats agree he was a ruthless
terrorist but some are raising concerns
about the strike itself that includes
senator Elizabeth Warren who told me
last night she has questions about the
timing is he a terrorist did he deserve
to be killed he is a senior government
official and here's the thing we've
known about him for a very long time
why didn't this happen a month ago why
didn't happen a month from now why right
now as Donald Trump faces a potential
impeachment trial in the United States
Senate
less than a month remains until the
caucuses here in Iowa and of course we
come here because not only are they
first but they have a very good track
record of picking the winner since 1976
the winner the Democratic caucus has
gone on to win the Democratic
presidential nomination seven out of
nine times gale the exceptions in 1988
Michael Dukakis and Bill Clinton in 1992
I'm writing that down ed because seven
out of nine times that's a pretty good
track record thank you very much we'll
be watching
you